you know I love tacos I don't think
better than just crushing tacos getting
paid to eat them and this weekend you
have a chance to be paid to eat tacos
it's like a dream come true the great
Las Vegas Taco Fest kicks off today
Craig Branch Park living the dream
Candace Charles joining us live after
you've already had some I'm so delish
but now you can eat tacos and win cash
yeah that's true I mean you know the
tacos were delicious it's a little early
to do it but you know what you can come
out here at five o'clock tomorrow and
Sunday at 11 and get in on eating that
tacos for some cash but besides that you
get to enjoy things like this rides for
the family for the kiddos there's of
course a lot of booths here and project
Taco is behind it all and I'm joined by
the founder of project Taco a great mind
and great heart Jesse Coronado thank you
so much for joining us tell us about the
great Las Vegas taco festival you guys
have been around for six years we have
been around for six years we are proud
to say we are the largest taco festival
in Nevada and we're gonna try to grow
this and make it even bigger Mariachis
Folklorico Lucha Libre carnival rides
car shows yes that is you name it and
mostly the tacos just sell themselves
right that's just a given taco tacos and
more tacos more than 25 local taco
vendors and as we mentioned a chance to
win some cash for eating tacos tell us
about that
we have a eating competition you know we
want to try to find the person that can
eat the most tacos in 15 minutes 15
minutes guys 15 minutes the record I
think right now is about 80. so that's a
pretty big one but we want to bring
somebody from Las Vegas to come and beat
that and let's go get this nice and
they're like the smaller ones so it's
it's possible but besides that project
Taco is all about giving back with their
motto taking action curing others you
guys are doing a multiple things to
really uplift that model tell us about
those things you know we uh we you know
we between uh all the stuff that's going
around in the world right now you kind
of want to give something back and do
something positive so what we did is
that uh for our parking fees this year
we're donating all of it back to the
family the Fallen police officers uh
we've got uh we're donating from the
actual car show to the injured police
officers funds uh plus a few other
organizations that that's more of a
surprise than when we do that to them
here at the at the Festival this year
okay sounds good well it sounds like
it's gonna be a great time thank you
Jesse for chatting with us and thank you
for all that you do in the community we
really appreciate it you guys can all
check it out starting today at five
o'clock if you miss it it's okay you can
come at Saturday and Sunday at 11. today
wraps up at 10. so you know plenty of
time to come on down here tickets are
just 12 bucks as well I got all the
details for you of course on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from Craig
Ranch Park we're at the great Las Vegas
taco festival will be taking place I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now 80